é que eu vou gravar hoje vamos lá ver
fique muito jovem o que olha o pessoal
de quem fala é o dar que seja muito bem
vindo a mais grave que em um jogo
bastante diferente muito fácil perigos
para a fifa mais ingrata não isso não
esqueça ou cometeu o que eu tenho a
pesquisar e vai ser agora um fio 2017 e
uma empresa num jogo para testar a
equipe louca estou aqui com uma velha
amiga
olha só a primeira bola que já têm
instruções goleiro van der sar ben
player 2 na cima baixo direito certa
essa sempre deu japão dar domingo outro
game no brasil em 2007 em português
chegarão 1080p e aqui no canal e
marquinhos 60 frames 32 um pai olha só o
campo antes do fim de junho
randy phillips que nem a mãe nem por
isso o brasil e andar na montanha
youhooo um plano para o hu hospital
agora então não chutou não olha pra mim
eu próprio tenho a lei
para coisa eu parei pra bola entrasse na
lei para nenê nesse botão portanto aí
vai um alento usar alicoop foi atrás da
baliza foi mentira aquilo que o nome uma
coisa agora é marcar um tac e não do
tabaco desde os beneficia
no cubo para não escutar muito gato sabe
é assim né não apoiei o meu deus não
gosto e cheiro com um buzinão não
convenceu uma nova go não tem fim
olha o mapa matou porque não vai buscar
o bolo br
ela vai ficar debaixo de um carro em
chamas é do órgão porque vai comer a
quem mandou no ângulo não é o gol oú o
futuro começa muito bem e ganhei foi
ontem por de perto quem é quem cuida da
mãe para o filho mais novo
falam não é e como assim não passou o
dia todo mas só depois sentindo o joelho
eu estou é esse sistema o estado passa
pelo canal do pico afastamento criar
somente um fifa 2018 nem por aí vai
isaac rock